I was using my favorite red pen to write with yesterday, but unfortunately it
had an accident. It exploded all over my piece of paper, and you can see I
ended up with a pretty big mess. I even got it all over my hands. I don't know
if you can tell but my fingers were pretty red yesterday. Now, the big problem
however, is that I lost a bunch of the work I had done. I started out with a
polynomial and then found all of its zeros. But now I can only see three of
them. Think you can make it out here. 1, 2 and i. So I'm trying to figure out
how much work I need to do to figure out my last zero. Do I need to actually
recalculate it? To answer this question, please just write yes or no in this
box. In the event that you write no in this box, and we can find this fourth
zero without really doing any math at all, write what the fourth zero is in
this box.